teams that take a 3-1 lead in the NBA
Finals have won 35 times and lost just
once Denver Nuggets now just one win
away from the first championship and
their franchise history Chris Miles here
with Jamal Crawford Kenny to Jet Smith
and Isaiah Thomas and we are presented
by State Farm this is game time live at
the finals here's the deal
back-to-back wins on the road in the NBA
Finals by double digits there's so many
things to break down but Isaiah what
stood out most to you in this particular
game fourth
Denver is just better I mean you know
their their size their offensive
execution their Poise the way they play
they play together and they really have
an answer to everything that Miami is
trying to do
we said the other night that the Joker
has all the answers to the test
and Denver really has all the answers
offensively to what Miami is trying to
do to them defensively well in Miami
Heat have proved everyone wrong up until
this point you you when they played the
Boston Celtics you said man for man they
have every Advantage Boston Celtics they
have to size in certain positions with
brown and Tatum and then all of a sudden
they go up 3-0 so they just just all the
disclaimers that you all of the
disproved all the disclaimers but now
you said well Denver has the same thing
you know 610 Porter 610 6-8 Gordon and
on the perimeter Joker and this is the
first team that's actually proving them
right that they're they can punish you
for being outmanning you in certain
positions and that's what's happening no
one else to this playoffs has been able
to do that to the Miami Heat on a
consistent basis except for them they're
playing great basketball both of them
are but Denver is just a higher level of
Miami everything you can do we can do
better and right now like Zeke and Jetta
said Miami's just ran out of talent it
comes down and you both can have schemes
you both can work hard you both can do
the right things you both can play the
right way now let's just out Talent you
right now that's what Denver's doing the
only other time I've seen this happen
where the Denver Nuggets fans are
staying in here they've come down
screaming the whole arena is screaming
Mexico you thought they were saying
Celtics yeah
[Applause]
but they're screaming only other time
I've seen this was when the Toronto
Raptors fans traveled like this yeah yes
and they would scream in the arena after
the arena and stay in there for 15
minutes afterwards this is what you're
witnessing Chris welcome to the NBA
finals welcome baby hey first time here
and that is an amazing thing to see I
was like what are all those people over
there chanting and it's the fans that
took the road trip down to Miami and had
a good time
double-digit wins now their defense
showed up the Miami Heat one and six in
the postseason right when they score
under 100 points three of those games
have come in this series and three of
those losses have now come to them is
that Joker's brother no it doesn't yeah
you know he's there
we should bring them on that guy in the
hotel today
I was like who the hell is this big ass
I jumped in the elevator I was like I'm
not going in there by myself
he's famous no no no those aren't his
brothers those are the guys from taking
five
oh yeah that's why yeah okay now I
understand the toughness yeah like when
you see it in every business well
actually the Joker is the skinniest one
yeah you see it in person it's real and
that that ain't fat that's muscle no
those guys do all the neck uh weights
and everything like that no don't
question but you know
can we I'm gonna go to the other side
here's a team that's down three one
we'll go there what does the Miami Heat
do I I've only I think I think I might
be the only one in the position that
been in the three down three one and
been on a team that's been able to come
back the difference I think with the
Miami Heat is we had we had the it
factor with Hakeem Olajuwon Hakeem
olajron and the dream and the dream
the it factor and the other thing that
you had you had to have a division of
delusion you had to like really believe
something was going to happen that could
not happen and you had to be delusional
and so we go oh
this is exactly we were exact same
position we said oh if we go there
and we go 3-2
we're not losing games we're not going
to come back and lose now game seven all
the pressures on them Phoenix and we're
gonna just stay close and then it's on
them
but you have to have delusion you have
to have it Jimmy now has to change his
game
he's been an all-around player he has to
be a scorer in this series it seems like
for them to win but the difference is
Denver has come to your house and beat
you by double digits in both games we
lost to Phoenix by double digits
yeah all three of them you had Hakeem
and Elijah one in dream and Denver has
the best player in the series they have
the Joker and you know just all of us
watching him in the back play
we're not getting ready to say he's the
greatest big man to ever play in all of
that
but
he
you're the smartest
big man to ever play because Define that
Define that because he has an answer
to every problem that you throw at him
he's the most unique big man if you play
man to man right he he can post you if
you double team him he's an excellent
passer if you play a Zone against him he
sets it up and play weak side he's
unselfish you know and and when you talk
about just reading the defense
you know he reads the defense better
than most big men most point guards yeah
and most points I mean so
Kareem Shaq will
you know Walt them them guys they they
were good offensively but I'm just
talking about in terms of they were good
scoring wise but in terms of just
just like knowing exactly what to do how
to do when to do it not from a scoring
standpoint but okay but then they have
to Shaq didn't have to do that
he didn't like you never not made him
feel uncomfortable enough to figure out
he stayed on addition he never went to
multiplication of division no hear what
I'm saying I I'm I'm talking intellect
right I ain't talking like scoring so
when you put this type of defense
against him he knows exactly where to go
not to get himself a bucket right but to
get to totally distort your defense he's
the guy that if you're if you're
coaching kids like I do and the kids are
doing something and me and my assistant
coach say no no go do it like this he's
the guy that's going to do it like this
like he's playing with kids the
difference between him and those other
guys is the fact that they're scoring
first he's scoring last like he's
playing a whole different game so it's a
it's it's how do you figure out that
arithmetic if you haven't seen it before
at that position I think I've seen it
it's just who's been like that I just
haven't seen it in a six eleven seven
foot body you know it's magic he wasn't
for school first okay okay he does
exactly what magic did he just battled
your whole defense you play zone you
play whatever he shoots the three start
learning two to three and LeBron like
the same way like he just went in
younger LeBron at certain times would
just dismantle your defense and he would
post you and then when he learned how to
post adoption but from the center
position
he's really the only one who because of
his unique body type and everything else
he's the only one who I think gets those
quiz questions with Shaq he's like
you're never gonna get to that because
oh no no I'm gonna score so much
you know what I mean for the audience
watching we are not saying
Jack and the Joker are in the same
league okay that ain't what we're saying
okay we talking we're talking basketball
intellect right you know with the
god-given talents that you have we're
talking we're talking from the neck up
okay right from the neck up in terms of
how he sees and understands the game
he's just how he makes it yeah and if if
Magic Johnson was playing in today's NBA
that's how he'd look he would be a
center in today's NBA he wouldn't be a
point guard listen to the names we're
saying with him though yeah but magic
LeBron but Shaq like we're saying
all-time great we're talking like the
intellect again from the neck up and
that's what that's right would you put
Larry to say yes yes that's diverse
that's what's killing Miami right right
it's his basketball IQ it's his interlay
like I said the other night he has all
the answers to the test so whatever you
whatever equation you give him right
he's got the answer to this he's so good
he's not even playing against the Miami
Heat players he's playing against Oster
yes his mind is playing against poster
oh you want to do that okay I have a
comment for that he's playing a whole
different game the last thing I'll say
on this Chris
coach Smith used to have the late great
Dean Smith had he used to have a say
when we used to walk on the floor he
said we're not playing against the
opponent we're playing like golf we're
playing the course so we're playing the
course this is a part four we have to
get there in four we have to get there
in three so we never we had certain
rules that we would do against anything
and he has rules in his head no matter
what happens this is what I'm going to
do you double me here I'm looking A or B
he's playing golf where everybody else
is playing basketball so here's the
question for you as far as the Denver
Nuggets winning this game because
nine minutes 34 seconds left in the
fourth quarter the Miami Heat crowds
into it Joker gets his fifth foul and
we've talked about it all season
non-nicola jokic minutes that's the
weakest part of the Denver Nuggets the
only way they don't win is if Nicola
jokic has to sit he sits for five
minutes they hold that lead how do they
do we were saying that when Jamal Murray
wasn't all the way right
now you put him back in you equate him
and now everybody else is playing Aaron
Gordon in in brown scored 48 points yeah
uh Joker and Jamal Murray scored 38
points yeah what team can do that they
were the two best players are outscored
by a bench player in their third or
fourth option the the 1989 Detroit
Pistons
with his fiance Builders championship
teams oh yeah my bad can we we got
two point guards and the guy who started
his career as a point guard and we've
had a magnificent series from a guy
who's developed into a guy that can
create for others and that's Jamal
Murray let's show him some love right 10
assists zero turnovers in this game what
he also had his fourth consecutive game
to start the NBA Finals with Tim or more
assists first player in NBA history to
do that see